bonjour à toutes et tous pour cette
carte blanche je vous demande
d'applaudir AAM Surot qui va me
rejoindre sur
scène donc AAM surau philosophe
écrivaine et traductrice américaine
d'origine égyptienne bienvenue je vous
invite à vous installer au
pupitre vous avez travaillé pendant 11
ans à l'Unesco Département des sciences
humaines et de philosophie vous êtes
philosophe écrivain et traductrice
américaine donc euh après avoir
travaillé à l'Unesco vous êtes lancé
dans l'écriture notamment des comptes
pour la jeunesse des comptes inspiré des
histoires des m nuits qui vous été
raconté par votre grand-mère un de vos
grands succès notamment qui a été adapté
au théâtre et l'homme assis dans lequel
vous posez la question du rapport des
enfants à la pauvreté un autre sujet
important pour vous également est la
condition de la femme et des relations
entre les hommes et les femmes et en
2008 vous fondez l'association Pierre
Claver qui est une école gratuite à
destination des de demandeur d'asile
dans lesquels des cours sont proposés de
français d'histoire et de littérature
vous analysez également l'actualité
françaises et les activités sportives et
culturelles vous vous définissez comme
une
humaniste et vous êtes dans le
prolongement de la philosophie de Martin
Buber philosophe compteur et pédagogue
isarelo autrichien sa philosophie
pourrait se synthétiser en toute vie
réelle et
rencontre concrètement votre
humaniste se peut se um dans cette
théorie philosophique qu'on ne vit
réellement qu'en rencontrant l'autre en
l'incluant dans un dialogue qui accepte
de percevoir son prisme son
interprétation du monde nous sommes donc
ici pour parler immigration bienvenue à
Yam Suro je suis absolument ravie d'être
à vos côté pour cette carte blanche et
je vous laisse la parole
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup pour cette
présentation qui m'a rappelé à moi-même
mon histoire
et et merci à vous merci au Modem et à
Monsieur vaou de m'inviter car je suis
très sensible et très honoré par cette
invitation je j'ai en effet fondé une
association qui s'appelle Pierre Claver
qui a maintenant 15 ans J a passé les 15
dernières années de ma vie qui ont été
des années extrêmement riches et je suis
particulièrement heureuse en ces temps
où nous réfléchissons beaucoup à l'asile
et à imigration de vous
apporter non pas un point de
vue sûrement pas des
recommandations de
politique mais des une réflexion née de
l'observation que j'ai pu faire au
contact avec les 5000 réfugiés que j'ai
rencontré dans les 15 dernières années
15000 réfugiés c'est 15000 histoires
c'est 15000 visages c'est 5 pardon 5000
pas 15000 5000
rencontres des drames comme vous savez
les drames de leur départ le drame de
leur voyage et le drame de leur
intégration mais j'ai choisi de ne pas
du tout prendre ce chemin-là pour le
l'intervention qu'on m'a qu'on m'a
demandé de faire mais alors pas du tout
je vous propose au contraire de contenir
l'émotion que suscite le le sujet même
de l'asile quel joli mot et les drames
qui ont eu lieu en
Méditerranée ainsi que les réactions
contradictoires qui sont engendrés par
l'émotion je vais tenter de regarder
bien en face ce problème qui est vous
l'avez dit un des grands défis de notre
époque de le regarder de manière
responsable l'émotion du public a été
vous le savez
dans les 20 dernières années la seule
conseillère des politiques publiques en
terme
d'immigration et nous avons désormais en
France des rêveurs de gauche qui
plaident pour l'ouverture des frontières
sans se soucier que leur option
généreuse ouvre sans doute des nouvelles
routes de l'esclavage autofinancier
cette fois et des rêveurs de droite qui
espèrent murer la France par un
accroissement de surveill
co
policière les deux
positions sont
irréalisables
impraticable ce que je voudrais noter
ici c'est que la question du flux
migratoire est toujours posé par les
deux camps en terme de
comment avons-nous ou non la capacité
c'est-à-dire les moyens d'accueillir
tous ces étrangers
comment les répartir équitablement en
Europe comment distinguer les migrants
des réfugiés comment empêcher les
migrants d'entrer en Europe ou de mourir
sur nos
côtes pour faire face à ce qu'on a
appelé la crise migratoire l'Europe a en
effet proposé un agenda en trois points
répartir l'accueil des réfugiés entre
les membres de l'Union organiser le tri
entre migrants et demandeurs d'asile
dans les pays de frontière et exercer
une pression diplomatique et financière
sur les pays d'origine ou de transit des
migrants pour qu'ils retiennent le
ressortissant ou les empêche de venir ou
de mourir encore une fois sur nos côtes
donc accueil partagé contrôle mise à
distance voilà les trois mots d'ordre ce
sont trois réponses à la question
comment et aucune des solutions n'a
fonctionné un échec
total chaos dans les pays de frontières
absence de solidarité entre les pays
européens qui devaient partager la
charge et surtout en aucun cas la
diminution du nombre de migrants bien au
contraire donc pour changer je vous
propose de poser les question autrement
en terme de
pourquoi pourquoi c'est-à-dire pour quel
motif ces personnes quittent-elles leur
pays pourquoi
c'est-à-dire à quelle
fin avons-nous le désir ou croyons-nous
être contraint d'accueillir les
ressortissants des pays les plus pauvres
et enfin pourquoi c'est-à-dire au nom de
quoi une politique migratoire serait
qualifiée de
responsable quelle serait une politique
d'immigration appropriée pour répondre à
quelle cause à quelle fin et au nom de
quoi elle serait
appropriée il me semble que sans réponse
à ces
interrogations on ne saura jamais mettre
en
œuvre quoi que ce soit car l'efficacité
d'une politique est
inséparable de la légitimité de
l'autorité que seul confèrent les
raisons qui précident à notre
action or lorsqu'on pose les questions
en terme de
pourquoi on rencontre assez
rapidement quelque chose que
j'appelleraiis l'ambivalence de nos
motivations en matière
d'immigration je commence par le premier
point pourquoi les migrants
migrent-ils la première raison c'est que
c'est
possible parce que l'Europe applique le
droit
d'asile fluide à l'intérieur blindé à
l'extérieur moi j'adore cette définition
je ne sais pas de qui elle est
l'Europe pour permettre la circulation
des citoyens en même temps que les biens
les capitaux les marchandises dans
l'espace Schengen a verrouillé ses
frontières extérieures cette fermeture
des frontières extérieures de l'Europe
était la contrepartie indispensable à la
circulation à l'intérieur de l'espace
européen or la forteresse Europe comme
on l'appelle est très fragile elle est
fragile parce qu'elle maintient le droit
d'asile que tous les états membres sont
signé ils sont tous signataires de la
Convention de Genève mais cette
convention de Genève qui date de 1951 je
crois on vous le répète en permanence
sur tous les médias reste marqué par le
contexte de son adoption
elle a été adoptée en pleine
après-gerre dans un contexte de guerre
froide avec une concurrence idéologique
entre deux bloc le bloc du monde libre
et le bloc
soviétique
elle est adoptée au milieu des
conséquences de la
Choa avec des millions d'apatrid à
protéger
elle est aussi dès son origine un
instrument idéologique
puissant qui opère dans un contexte de
bipolarité idéologique c'est-à-dire
qu'elle est un instrument de combat
politique en offrant l'asile le monde
LIBRE se donne le droit c'est ça aussi
le droit d'asile il se donne le droit
d'accueillir et de protéger les
persécutés de l'autre bord et donc
surtout à le
décrédibiliser le contexte politique a
changé et la Convention de Genève a
d'ailleurs beaucoup
évolué mais l'Europe continue à exercer
ce droit de reconnaître et de protéger
les ressortissants d'autres États qui ne
sont plus nécessairement de l'autre bord
et je voudrais vous faire remarquer donc
que c'est
paradoxalement le droit d'asile
c'est-à-dire une manifestation de la
puissance européenne qui l'a condu
aujourd'hui au sentiment d'impuissance
que l'on
sait ainsi les demandeurs d'asile
continuent à être admis partout en
Europe sans
documents le droit d'asile permet
l'entrée irrégulière sur le territoire
national c'est en cela que je vous dis
ils viennent parce que c'est
possible et tant que ce sera possible
nous aurons n'en doutez pas des millions
de candidats à l'asile la deuxè raison
de migrer et que des millions d'êtres
humains sont en effet malheureux dans
leur
pays quitter son pays est devenu le
désir croissant de beaucoup de gens
maintenant ce désir universel de s'en
aller est avant
tout le résultat de la mondialisation
tout simplement assorti d'un mvement
raté de démocratisation dont vous avez
parlé tout à
l'heure la mondialisation a
globalement rendu beaucoup plus faible
le sentiment d'attachement des personnes
à leur pays qu'on appelait autrefois la
patrie partout pas seulement en Europe
partout les gens en Égypte en Côte
d'Ivoire en Afghanistan sont comme nous
tous beaucoup moins attachés au pays de
les ancêtres c'est un pur effet de
l'époque que nous ne commentons jamais
assez les modes de vie s'uniformisent
les idées les images se
déplacent et nous avons confondu en fait
j'y reviendrai la démocratisation et
lesess économique la trè incitation à
l'exil et nous n'en parlons presque
jamais c'est que ça n'en est plus un
nous sous-estimons toujours cette
nouveauté propre à notre époque et ses
conséquences
c'est que les exilés d'aujourd'hui ne
vivent pas du tout la même expérience de
l'exil que ceux qui ont pris la mer par
exemple pour aller à Ellis Island ils
partent sans partir sans cesse connectés
à leur pays leurs amis leur famille ils
peuvent grâce à la fluidité des échanges
maintenir leur mode de
vie leurs attaches avec leur pays
d'origine ils partent sans partir
vraiment et la décision de l'exil est
beaucoup plus facile
les réfugiés actuels ne deviennent pas
des apatrides très peu d'entre eux
quittent définitivement leur pays
d'ailleurs aussitôt qu'ils sont
naturalisés et ils sont naturalisés
extrêmement vite au nom de cette même
convention de Genève la plupart qui
auront argumenté à pr qu'il ne pouvaient
pas rentrer dans leur pays sous par
crainte de persécution reviennent
aussitôt avec un passeport européen qui
leur permet de de circuler librement ils
vivent en réalité une vie entre deux
pays et c'est une situation que la
Convention de Genève n'avait
certainement pas
prévue la troisième et je crois la plus
forte des raisons c'est qu'ils n'ont
plus aucun espoir dans l'avenir de leur
pays le cours de l'histoire s'est arrêté
pour
eux et
nous-même nous l'avons perdu pour eux
cet espoir puisque nous acceptons qu'il
franchissent des mil kilomè pour accéder
à nos démocraties en leur octroyant le
droit d'asile plutôt que de les aider à
travailler à les construire en ce
faisant nous contribuons parce que c'est
l'objet de la de la Convention de Genève
nous contribuons à décrédibiliser
définitivement tout effort politique de
résistance nous avons donc admis que les
non européens sont incapables d'opérer
des changements politiques sociau
culturels économiqu nécessaire dans le
temps et qu'ils feront en parcourant
l'espace ils feront cet effort qui les
sépare de
l'Europe nous avons confondu
développement économique et
démocratisation bien des pays que
quittent les migrants sont en situation
d'essort économique comme la Côte
d'Ivoire l'Égypte la Tunisie grâce à
l'aide au développement notamment
qu'offre l'Europe mais ils demeurent des
pays d'inéquité et d'oppression le fruit
de ce progrès économique que nous avons
beaucoup aidé
reste capté par une petite élite odieuse
et corrompue on entend souvent les
réfugiés viennent souvent viennent
chercher la protection politique tandis
que les migrants viennent chercher du
travail cette distinction est fausse
tous proviennent de sociétés
dysfonctionnelles tous viennent chercher
la protection sociale d'un état de droit
le salaire minimal l'accès universel à
l'éducation et à la santé l'égalité
devant la loi la possibilité de réaliser
dans le cours d'une vie un potentiel
humain de cela tous sont privés que les
pays d'où ils proviennent soi en guerre
ou non et secondaire pour une très
grande majorité d'entre eux je dirais
après 15 ans d'expérience au service des
réfugiés que la guerre est à la fois une
cause de départ et une opportunité de
demander l'asile en conclusion sur les
motifs qui poussent les migrantes à
migrer nous avons institué la
possibilité d'une immigration régulière
irrégulière nous avons démissionné de
tout effort de démocratisation et nous
nous sommes fait à
l'inverse les partenaires des États qui
font le malheur de leur peuple et qui
les poussent à
l'exil alors deuxème partie pourquoi
croyons-nous et pourou désirons-nous
être pourquoi croyons-nous être
contraint d'accueillir au titre de
l'asile les ressortissants des pays
pauvres
on avancera des idées des raisons
extérieures c'est-à-dire qui
contraignent les souverainetés
nationales parce que nous sommes
signataire de la Convention de Genève
nous avons une obligation
internationale parce que la coopération
entre pays européens nous y oblige mais
nous excipons aussi de raisons
historiques surtout en France comme ami
de la liberté le droit d'asile est très
ancien en France beaucoup plus ancien
que la
Révolution et nous sommes attachés
depuis la Révolution
au droits de l'homme l'asile figure sur
la Constitution il est donné à toute
personne en raison de son action pour la
liberté j'y suis personnellement
extrêmement attaché et c'est ce qui
motive surtout la sévérité du plaidoyer
que je
fais il reste une raison historique dont
on parle pas beaucoup en France et que
j'ai pu remarquer en travaillant dans
l'association c'est que beaucoup de
Français des millions de
Français souviennent de l'exil de de
l'exil pardon de leurs parents ou de
leurs grands-parents c'est un pays qui
est historiquement sensible à la
question de
l'exil comme nous l'avons vu récemment
avec les ukrainiens et le mouvement
extraordinaire de solidarité qu' a
provoqué en France ensuite il y a des
raisons morales sur lesquelles je passe
rapidement parce que c'est cell dont on
parle le plus souvent parce que nous
nous sentons obscurément coupa des
situations qui les font fuir leur
pays enfin nous justifions nos
politiques migratoires pour des raisons
économiques et démographiques parce que
nous aurions besoin de main d'œuvre
c'est ce qu'on voit ces jours-ci le plus
souvent dans les journaux ainsi nous
admetterions des étrangers au titre de
l'asile et exclusivement au titre de
l'asile et nous refusons l'immigration
économique de ceux qui viendraient parce
qu'il cherchent du travail parce que
nous ne trouvons pas d'autres moyens
pour palier à notre besoin de main
d'œuvre et à notre insuffisance
démographique est-il possible que nous
ayons besoin d'importer des hommes nés
ailleurs pour des raisons économiques et
strictement national et que nous
prétendions les accueillir pour des
raisons humanitaires contraints que nous
sommes par des obligations
internationales c'est cela l'ambivalence
et cette ambivalence conduit à une
distinction qui paraît tout à fait
paradoxale entre les réfugiés politiques
et les migrants économiques dont en
réalité nous aurions besoin nous
déclarons n'admettre que les réfugiés et
non les migrants preuve que nous
n'obéissons qu'à notre devoir politique
et humanitaire et non aux insuffisence
de nos politiques économiques alors que
c'est des travailleurs que nous aurions
besoin ce ne serait pas la première fois
dans l'histoire qu'une immigration
admise au nom de l'asile serent en même
temps des finalités économiques c'était
le cas par exemple lorsque la France a
donné le statut de réfugié à 150000
indochchinois entre 1979 et 1986 l'asile
est alors donné de manière quasi
automatique pratiquement sans audition
de
l'OFPRA pour décrédibiliser bien sûr un
opinion po un opposant politique mais
aussi pour profiter d'une opportunité
économique c'est-à-dire pour contourner
la fermeture de l'immigration de
l'immigration du travail qui a lieu dans
les dans le même temps et donc fournir
une main- d'œuvre indochchinoise réputée
docile et non syndiquée surtout au
secteur de l'industrie qui eux n'avaient
pas été touchés par la crise plutôt dans
les années 20 les exilés russes arrive
massivement en France l'asile qui leur
est donné manifeste d'abord une
opposition au régime soviétique mais
répond également à une logique
économique le besoin de main d'œuvre de
l'économie d'après-gerre l'image du
réfugié russe aristocrate
antibolchevique a effacé le souvenir du
plus grand nombre des immigrés russes
qui fuyent tout simplement la famine
dans les années 60 et ça c'est un
exemple très intéressant le le ministère
des Affaires étrangères donc nation
national craint que l'asile donné à un
trop grand nombre de yougoslaves ne
nuise aux relations de la France avec la
Yougoslavie non aligné de tit l'OFPRA
réduit immédiatement le nombre de
statutes accordé et des accords de main
d'œuvre sont signé pour permettre au
yougoslave d'accéder au marché du
travail de en
France le plus frappant et qu'on
continue de faire semblant d'être
contraint par nos engagements
internationaux alors que l'analyse
historique montre qu'il existe toujours
une volonté politique obéissant à des
logiques diplomatique économique
national le droit d'asile est
nécessairement lié aux fluctuations
politiques aux relations
diplomatique et à la politique qu'un
État veut veut conduire
ce n'est donc pas un droit neutre ce
droit d'asile il n'est pas distinct à
d'autres logiques il ne il ne l'est pas
aujourd'hui il ne l'a jamais
été pour finir maintenant et c'est le
plus important c'est au nom de quoi
est-ce qu'on pourrait faire une
politique migratoire
responsable c'est-à-dire au nom de quoi
elle serait légitime c'est ma partie la
plus courte parce que vous y répondez
tout en étant ici
elle est écrite là je je ne vois plus
maintenant parce que je ne truc mais il
y a écrit humanisme Europe solidarité
engagement
démocratie c'est au nom de cela que l'on
peut faire une politique migratoire
légitime il me semble que les
raisonnements économiques en faveur de
ou en rejet de l'immigration
oublie complètement de s'interroger sur
les beaucoup plus grandes questions et
interrogation que vous avez mentionné
tout à l'heure dans votre introduction
monsieur Baou c'est-à-dire sur les
transformations plus complexes plus
profonde de notre société la place du
travail par exemple dans la vie de nos
contemporains le gloubibouga entre
politique migratoire économique et
cetera évince totalement les questions
de fond des sociétés
européennes comment ne pas voir que dans
une qu'en installant une culture de
fluidité et de
circulation tant que nous souhaitons que
nos colis Amazon et nos pizzas soient
livrés à nos portes nous aurons besoin
de jambes or les migrants sont
exactement
cela ça c'était pas
mal les migrants sont exactement cela ce
sont des hommes qui
circulent ils viennent dans une société
qui met très haut la
circulation je trouve presque comique
une société qui se félicite que les
services et les marchandises circulent
sans cesse mais se méfi des migrants
dont la nature est de
circuler je ne veux pas vous rappeler le
temps du covid où ne circulaient que les
migrants ce que nous avons appelé les
métiers en tenstion car je vois bien que
mon intervention tombe en même temps que
des choses qui nous
préoccupent donc ces métiers en tenstion
pour lesqueles nous aurions besoin
d'immigration sont les métiers qui
nécessitent encore un corps humain des
pour creuser et construire des jambes
pour livrer et pour transporter des
mains pour servir pour soigner nos
malades nos enfants nos
vieillards c'est c'est en interrogeant
l'avenir c'est-à-dire au nom de quoi au
nom de la société qui vient que l'on
peut faire une politique responsable
est-ce que c'est bien celle-ci la
société que l'on
veut
avec une partie de la société j'essaie
de ne pas parler en couleur qui
resterait assise en
visio et une autre partie de la société
qui
circule pour la
servir ceci me paraît ouvrir une
réflexion politique bien plus profonde
sur ce que nous sommes bien plus
profonde que la question migratoire
immédiate qui nous est
posée il me semble qu'aujourd'hui ce
qu'on entend dans le débat sur la
politique migratoire
occulte la plupart des grandes
questions la question par exemple de la
lenteur de
l'intégration de son absence de son
inefficacité de son
échec cet échec on peut en parler plus
tard dans la discussion ce n'est pas
celui de l'immigration actuelle c'est
celui de 60 années
d'échec de l'intégration je pense que ce
qui rend les Français inquiets ce qui
rend la question de l'immigration très
inconfortable ce ne sont pas du tout les
les scènes que nous voyons à Lampedusa
et je ne dis pas que c'est ce sont pas
des choses importantes mais primordial
est de regarder en face l'échec en
France des 60 dernières années
d'intégration et ce qui se passe avec
l'ambivalence de nos motifs sur le sur
l'immigration c'est justement c'est que
on se trouve projeté dans une sorte de
sentiment d'urgence qui justifie toutes
sortes de mauvaises pratiques il le le
la demande d'asile a un caractère
dramatique il faut faire vite euh et
pour des raisons humanitaire le réfugié
se voit immédiatement attribuer un
logement social immédiatement un travail
et hop on dit qu'il est intégré à
condition d'avoir signé un document de
trois pages qui s'appelle le contrat
d'intégration républicaine voilà comment
nous intégrons les réfugiés et comment
voilà comment nous pensons cette fois-ci
que ça va mieux se passer que la
dernière
fois je pense
que je vais
conclure l'ambivalence inavouée des
motivations qui pré qui président au
politiques migratoires est à la fois
paralysante immorale et
dangereuse la préférence européenne pour
l'asile est un choix politique il est
prétendument respectueux des droits de
l'homme il fait mécaniquement venir en
Europe des millions de malheureux qui
continueront de traverser les océans les
montagnes et les et les déserts au péril
de leur vie pour tenter leurs Chan il
nous conduit en réalité à plus de
manquement au droits de l'homme qu'il ne
nous oblige à les respecter ce choix
dans un climat d'urgence humanitaire
permet d'apporter une réponse commode et
immédiate à un besoin de main d'œuvre et
d'évacuer les défis politiques à
beaucoup plus long terme auquel nous
devons faire
face ce qui me paraît particulièrement
immoral c'est de maintenir l'asile au
nom du bien et d'avoir ainsi le droit de
faire du
mal il faut en finir avec
l'instrumentalisation de la Convention
de Genève à des fins économiques
elle n'est pas adaptée au monde dans
lequel nous
vivons il faut définir une politique
migratoire plus conforme à l'honneur et
à l'intérêt de la France comme de
l'Europe et ceci exige de
restituer le statut exceptionnel de
l'asile politique il est l'héritage
d'une histoire douloureuse d'une
histoire européenne et il est un
magnifique h hérritage il faut
l'appliquer avec rigueur parce qu'il est
la réalisation laïque et politique
du commandement le plus élevé de tous un
commandement d'hospitalité envers toute
personne humaine qui demande la
protection d'un autre État que le
sien
pour restituer à l'asile son statut
d'exception il faut rétablir la
possibilité d'immigrer pour d'autres
raisons légalement pour venir travailler
en
France il faut ouvrir des guichets
consulaires il faut faire des demandes
en ligne il faut faire tout ce que l'on
peut pour rétablir l'immigration légale
puisque nous nous en avons besoin et
puisque de toute façon nous
l'admettons beaucoup de demandeurs
d'asile que j'ai rencontré dans les 15
dernières années aurent préféré immigrer
pour le
travail
ce qui est il faut maintenant aussi se
pencher et c'est très sérieux sur le
problème de l'intégration en France ce
qui est inconfortable aux Français je
l'ai déjà dit ce n'est pas le nombre des
immigrés c'est qu'il s'ajoute à la
faillite de l'intégration des 60
dernières années c'est un échec beaucoup
plus ancien il faut l'apprécier avec
courage et la naturalisation au bout de
3 ou 4
années d'un d'un réfugié est une
aberration une aberration personne n'a
le temps de s'intégrer en 34 ans c'est
une entreprise extrêmement
lourde ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que l'intégration ne concerne pas les
générations qui arrivent les générations
qui arrivent en bateau en traversant la
mer et
cetera ce n'est pas l'intégration ne les
concerne pas il concernent leurs enfants
et nous ne faisons rien nous ne faisons
rien en en terme d'intégration des
enfants nous nous admettons une
immigration familiale sans se préoccuper
du tout des femmes qui arrivent pour
rejoindre leurs époux réfugiés rien
elles n'arrivent pas au titre de l'asile
elles arrivent au titre de de la
réunification familiale c'est c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'immigration familiale
qui est d'ailleurs la plus
grande et nous ne faisons rien pour ces
femmes qui vont élever des enfants qui
vont vivre en France il ne faudra pas
s'étonner
que les enfants et les petits-enfants
des réfugiés qui sont aujourd'hui dans
l'état où ils sont c'est-à-dire
malheureux exploités isolés et pas
intégrés comme leurs prédécesseurs il ne
faudra pas s'étonner que leurs enfants
et leurs petits-enfants expriment du
ressentiment de plus le mauvaise
intégration et les mauvaises conditions
de vie des étrangers en France qui a
très mauvaise réputation comme pays
d'accueil malgré l'énormees dépenses
budgétairees cela éloigne les étrangers
mieux qualifiés dont peut-être nous
avons
besoin je crois que nous ne parvenons
pas excités par notre besoin immédiat de
main d'œuvre bon marché aveuglé par
notre mépris pour le reste du monde
attiré un avantage durable pour la
France et pour l'Europe de cette
immigration et donc je terminerai par là
je pense de la manière la plus urgente
et la lecture des journaux ne va pas
dans ce sens du
tout je crois que l'Europe que nous
devons refuser le piège dangereux qui
nous est tendu par tous les despotes
locaux dans les pays d'origine des
migrants notre crainte des migration est
devenue leur monnaie d'échange aucune
dictature par définition ne peut
contenir la ne peut tenir la promesse de
tenir l'migration c'est elle qui la
provoque l'Europe veut exercer une
pression sur les pays d'origine des
migrant c'est exactement l'inverse qui
se produira ce que nous faisons en fin
de compte en croyant bien faire c'est
alimenter chez les peuples opprimés le
les raisons de l'exil c'est alimenter
chez nous les raisons du
ressentiment c'est peut-être ce qu'il y
a de plus grave en fin de compte les
gouvernements ce qui sont démocratiques
et ceux qui ne le sont pas s'arrangent
entre eux mais ce sont les peuples ici
comme là-bas qui finiront par payer le
prix de ces
arrangements il faut espérer que les
opinions publiques des démocraties
européennes qui ont la chance de pouvoir
peser sur les décisions politiques de
leurs états refuseront un jour d'endurer
la triple peine à laquelle les
condamnent les politiques de gribouille
de leur gouvernement successif qu'ils en
auront assez
d'être les dindons d'une triple farce de
se rendre complice d'État
criminel d'endurer les effets des
idéologies nationalistes et xénophobes
que nous voyons réémerger et qui se
nourrissent uniquement de la peur de la
colère et de la lassitude des peuples
tout en portant la charge de millions de
rescapés de pays invivables je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
euh il faut que vous partiez on me dit
très vite c'est ça pardon il faut que
vous partiez très vite me
dit-on non vous restez je peux partir si
vous voulez non non c'est exactement le
contraire vous le savez bien non je
voulais vous dire
que
euh rarement euh on entend
euh une une pensée aussi puissante dans
une langue aussi
belle euh et c'est et c'est quelque
chose pour nous de
très de très heureux c'est précisément
pour cela que nous sommes ensemble et
que nous avons ces moments
là alors vous savez bien votre pensée
elle est révolutionnaire et moi je crois
ceux qui m'entendent parler de ces
sujets depuis longtemps je pense que
pour aussi difficile que soit la voix
que vous
ouvrez c'est la seule
possible mais ça nécessite évidemment de
sortir de toutes les hypocrisies avec
lesquelles nous vivons dans nos dans
notre langage de tous les jours y
compris le
mien car la distinction faite à longueur
de temps entre l'asile et l'autre
immigration est naturellement une
distinction complètement artificielle ce
n'est pas vrai
euh et donc euh
les les voies que vous ouvrez que nous
essayons d'ouvrir et que d'autres ont
essayé
d'ouvrir c'est-à-dire
reconnaître la
nature de l'immigration de sauvegarde
par le
travail de l'immigration de sauvegarde à
condition que nous ayons une exigence
d'effort vers l'intégration
et que donc nous sachions à quoi nous
voulons
intégrer ce que nos sociétés ont oublié
depuis longtemps si il nous reste la
laïcité qui est un en effet quelque
chose de très important que nous ne
savons pas expliquer et que nous ne
savons pas faire aimer par ceux
qui veulent nous
rejoindre et donc je trouve que votre
pensée votre regard votre expérience
sont infiniment précieuses et j'aurais
aimé que si vous avez le temps vous nous
disiez
concrètement quels sont à votre avis les
pour ouvrir la discussion les décisions
urgentes à prendre quelle est leur forme
parce que plaide par moi je plaide par
par exemple
pour au fond des choses assez proches de
la carte verte aux États-Unis
c'est-à-dire une autorisation de travail
à temps avec possibilité d'aller et de
retour dans un monde qui oui fluide hein
comme vous l'avez très bien expliqué ils
viennent pour beaucoup d'entre eux en
disant que ils sont persécutés dans leur
pays et quand ils ont les papiers ils
reviennent dans leur pays pour pour pour
revoir son pays et donc si vous pouviez
nous nous dire si vous avez une idée des
décisions con de quelques décisions
concrètes que par lesquelles nous
pourrions alimenter la réflexion de fond
si stimulante que vous nous avez
présenté merci pour vos
mots nous avons tous lu ou peut-être
pas il y a une loi qui arrive qui est la
loi asile et immigration voilà une chose
concrète
elle elle elle contient pas mal de
bonnes choses et
certaines qui sont fatales parmi les
pratiques que nous
avons vous vous disiez il y a deux
choses c'est-à-dire il faut travailler à
l'intégration et nous vraiment nous ne
savons pas le faire et je disais aussi
et travailler à ne pas désintégrer le
reste du monde aussi c'est un pendant
important mais ici nous sommes en France
donc prenons le premier
volet
accueillir des des des gens au titre de
l'asile d'accord c'est lorsque je dis il
prétend d'être persécuté et après ils
partent il faut bien voir que ils sont
obligés de mentir sinon ils auraient pas
lesî donc nous les obligeons à ce
mensonge c'est pour ça qu'il faut
absolument sortir de du du contexte de
la Convention de Genève je pense que
le
l'intégration est beaucoup plus lente
beaucoup beaucoup plus lente qu'on ne
croit ça n'est pas avoir un job avoir un
logement ça n'est même pas seulement
parler français on peut parler français
ne pas être intégré ça c'est vraiment un
des grands fantasme français c'est il
faut parler français et on est intégré
c'est pas vrai ce n'est pas vrai du tout
je crois par exemple que le la
naturalisation est trop rapide en terme
de temps et elle ne repose pas sur des
conditions suffisantes
je vous donne un exemple qui moi me
choque
énormément les réfugiés afghans par
exemple obtiennent tous les réfugiés
malâ afghans obtiennent tous l'asile au
bout de 34 ans aucune de leurs femmes en
tout cas aucune de celles que j'ai connu
ne l'a ni demandé ni obtenu à
forceorie
jamais c'est très très intéressant alors
pourquoi est-ce que les femmes ne
demandent pas la naturalisation comme si
elles étaient maintenues même si elles
sont sur le territoire national sous une
loi qui n'est pas la nôtre elles sont
comme entre parenthèses elles vivent par
ailleurs dans un état d'isolement humain
et social
épouvantable et très peu d'effort est
fait pour leur
intégration parce que c'est très
difficile ils ont des enfants elles ont
enceintes elles ont trois enfants en
basâge comment voulez-vous qu'elles se
rendent au cours de français donc ils
son exempté les femmes sont exemptées
des cours et de l'intégration ce sont
elles qui élèvent les enfants de
demain donc la première chose c'est ça
c'est cette histoire de naturalisation
je trouve qu'elle est très très très
rapide je trouve qu'aussi les condition
à laquelle on elle est donnée c'est je
trouve que ça n'est pas suffisant de
d'appeler un homme en entretien
singulier quand on sait que cet homme a
une famille on ne sait pas dans quelles
conditions elle elle vit et donc c'est
les conditions
auquel on donne la nationalité française
et donc un passeport européen à une
personne sont tout à fait
insuffisante ça c'est une chose ensuite
il y a ce discrédit sur l'asile et et ça
c'est une des choses dans la loi
d'immigration que je trouve extrêmement
contestable il y a vous savez il y a les
bons et les gentils et les méchants
avait dit Monsieur Darmanin on va être
gentil avec les gentils on va être
méchant avec les méchants maintenant
parmi les gentils
par les gentilles en fait ce sont les
gens les étrangers qui travaillent ici
clandestinement qui travaillent parfois
depuis des années dans des très
mauvaises conditions puisqu'ils
travaillent au noir et donc il s'agirait
de
les de les régulariser une fois pour
toutes on crie à l'appel
d'air ce que je crois surtout c'est que
c'est un discrédit absolument
extraordinaire sur l'asile lui-même car
beaucoup de ces clandestins sont
d'anciens déboutés du droit d'asile
et ça je trouve
inacceptable c'est absolument
inacceptable
d'avoir d'avoir accueilli au nom de
l'asile c'est-à-dire d'un principe
absolument sacré des demandeurs d'asile
vendez compte demander l'asile comme
c'est puissant d'avoir une offre si
généreuse en terme matériel une
allocation temporaire le temps qu'on
instruise le le le dossier un logement
lorsque c'est possible et c'est devenu
souvent possible l'accès à la santé
l'accès à l'éducation pour les enfants
tout ça c'est avant qu'on ait même
décidé que cet étranger avait ou non
vocation à
l'asile et une fois que l'on a trouvé
que l'OFPRA a statué que non il n'avait
pas vocation à demander l'asile selon
les critères que que nous avons cette
personne ne quitte en fait jamais la
France moi en 15 ans je n'ai vu personne
quittit la France j'ai vu énormément de
gens débouter par par l'OFPRA et la CNDA
c'est la commission nationale du droit
d'asile je n'ai vu personne qui était la
France les gens sont en effet
travaillent et sont
régularisés une des premières choses à
faire pour restituer le statut de
l'asile c'est de régulariser en effet
des personnes qui travaillent depuis je
ne sais pas combien de temps parfois 20
ans en France de les régulariser de de
qu'il payent des impôts que ce soit
voilà qu'on que l'on soit digne de la
société que l'on veut une société juste
que l'on veut mais qu'en aucun cas
quelqu'un qui a commencé par demander
l'asile soit régularisé pour d'autres
raisons il a choisi le tapis rouge et il
a joué avec ce que nous avions de plus
sacré mais pour le pour faire cela pour
être rigoureux avec l'asile il faut
avoir il faut avoir établi l'immigration
légale ça tourne en rond il ne peut pas
on ne peut pas le faire on ne peut pas
être rigoureux si on ne on laisse
l'asile comme la seule voie possible à
l'immigration bien sûr que tout le monde
viendra dans leur esprit vous savez ils
n'ont pas lu la Convention de Genève les
migrants dans leur esprit ils ils y ont
droit ils sont malheureux ils vivent
sous des gouvernements opprimés
oppressifs malheureusement ces
gouvernements sont également nos alliés
mais ça ça ça rend la chose encore plus
désespérée pour
eux donc restituer la place de l'asile
comme comme statut absolument
exceptionnel rétablir l'immigration
légale rendre possible de demander
l'immigration partout ailleurs qu'en
France pas du tout là dans il faut
fermer tout en France il faut tout tout
fermer et rendre possible chaque fois
que je dis ça on me dit mais vous rendez
compte les que devant les consulats bah
les que devant les consulats sont
préférables au au simtière de la
Méditerranée c'est quand même
incroyable et ces gens traversent le
monde entier un Afghan pour arriver en
France pour arriver en France d'accord
donc vous voyez bien que cette décision
de l'exil n'est pas un asile première
minute vous voyez traverse l'Iran où la
France a un consulat la Turquie où la
France a des consulats la Grèce
partout il faut rétablir la possibilité
de demander à migrer à immigrer en
France et se débarrasser une fois pour
toutes de ce mot épouvantable qui est
migrant on on veut émigrer de son pays
on veut venir en France on demande à la
France d'imigrer dans et la France dit
oui ou non de manière souveraine mais
elle n'est pas là avec un couteau sur la
gorge sous la gorge et des des millions
de personnes qui arrivent sur sur les
côtes de l'Europe des centaines de
milliers qui se noient dans la
Méditerranée c'est inhumain et c'est de
notre fitte c'est de notre
faitte il ne faut pas imaginer les
migrants comme une sorte de lave vous
savez qu' sort de l'EUR de l'Afrique
c'est ce sont des décisions personnelles
ce sont des décisions volontaires ch
chacun de ces migrants est un homme est
un homme responsable qui a pris la
décision de quitter son pays et de venir
en
Europe ils sont appelé par le droit
d'asile et donc
concrètement remettre le droit d'asile à
sa place restituer la possibilité
d'immigrer et dans l'intégration se
souvenir il n'y a pas que la laïcité se
souvenir ce que c'est que
l'Europe et qu'intégrer l'Europe c'est
adhérer aux principes qui sont les siens
aux convictions qui sont les
siennes l'Europe n'est pas un réservoir
d'opportunités et l'Afrique un réservoir
de main
d'œuvre il faut se souvenir ce qu'est
l'Europe c'est pour ça que je vous
disais c'est écrit sur le tableau là-bas
il faut se souvenir ce que c'est il n'y
a pas que la laïcité ce que je trouve
très difficile par exemple dans dans
dans notre école qui essaie d'intégrer
des des
réfugiés la laïcité ils ont un peu de
mal mais on y arrive pourquoi parce que
c'est la loi voilà ce qui est beaucoup
plus difficile beaucoup plus difficile
pour tous les réfugiés c'est cette
notion d'égal dignité devant la
loi pour vous c'est une chose
tellement banale que vous n'en voyez
même pas le caractère spécifiquement
européen
ça c'est le ça c'est notre
[Applaudissements]
héritage merci pour continuer tout petit
pe plus l'échange j'aurais voulu qu'on
entend le témoignage de Christian
vanobel vice-président modem de l'INE et
qui est à l'origine de la rédaction d'un
livret d'accueil accueillir intégrer les
réfugiés en milieu
rural
mesames messieurs
bonsoir merci Madame sur merci Monsieur
pour votre analyse de ce de ce sujet
délicat et
surtout personne n insensible en réalité
au sort qui est réservé à ces personnes
qui ont perdu leur foyer je crois qu'on
m pas parlé de la notion de perte de
foyer je crois que quand on a un réfugié
qu' est le statut ou pas la notion de
perte de foyer c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui doit rester en arrièrepensée
je vous remercie de me donner la parole
c'est parce qu'en faiton la semaine
dernière par la direction
interministérielle à l'accueil et à
l'intégration des réfugiés donc d'un
d'un livré d'un fasicule qui s'appelle
accueillir et intégrer les les personnes
réfugiées en milieu rural
et donc auquel j'ai participé en tant
que que maire d'un petit village je suis
maire d'un village qui s'appelle Sisson
dans l'INE qui est un département du
Nord de la France village de 200 100
habitants et nous hébergeons des
réfugiés donc depuis 2018 depuis le mois
d'août 2018 pour un village 200
actuellement nous sommes à 115 réfugiés
c'estàdire au début nous avions accepté
avec une association accueil et
promotion de d'éberger 60 réfugiés qui
arrivaient donc par qui étaient des
réfugiés réinstallés c'estàd qui étaient
donc initialement dans des camps au
Tchad ou au nigère et qui sont arrivés
et il restait 3 mois donc à Sisson puis
ensuite était euh
le temps de refaire leurs papiers et
ensuite ils étaient redispatchés dans le
département ou dans d'autres
département au bout d'un an et demi ça
se passait bien on nous a demandé de
passer en CPH ce qui fait qu'en fait on
est passé on est resté avec 60 avec
toujours avec des Cortes au lieu de
rester 3 4 mois il restaiit donc 7 8 ou
9 mois et après on nous a demandé donc
de de d'avoir 20 places d'urgence
supplémentaire et 35 places de cada ce
qui fait qu' fa actuellement on est à
115 réfugiés sur le village donc voilà
alors je dis que ça se passe très bien
contrairement à ce qui s s'est passé à
kak
et contrairement à ce qui s'est passé à
Kalak c'est mon grand âge
excusez-moi je suis un vieux monsieur ça
sera peut-être plus facile d' non vous
m'entendez mieux là non ça va
oui c'est un peu suite à ce qui s'est
passé à Calac et à Saint-Brévin que
Monsieur Alain Renny a proposé de mettre
en place ce ce ce fcicule sur l'accueil
et la et l'intégration des réfugiés en
milieu rural en se disant que tout qu'
fait on a une une crainte que beaucoup
de mèes sont sont très très frileux
vis-à-vis de de cet accueil là alors que
moi pour moi ça c'est ça s'est très très
bien passé al ça s'est bien passé
peut-être que j'ai de la chance euh j'ai
peut-être fait une d'une autre façon
toujours est-il que moi je pense que
c'est de la qualité de l'accueil que
résulte toutes les les la suite des des
relations qu'on peut avoir par la suite
et je crois que ça c'est très très
important quand on quand j'avais été
sollicité donc au MO au mois de décembre
2017 donc avec cette association plus un
bailleur social on j'avais rencontré
donc c ces
personnesl avec 10 autres de mes de mes
de mes colistiers on un conseil
municipal de 19 personnes donc on était
à 11 donc on les a reçu et puis donc on
a été ému parce qu' par le projet et on
a dit oui tout de suite alors bien sûr
quand on dit oui après bon c'était il
répondait à un appel à projet la réponse
à l'appel à projet été lancé par la
préfecture donc ils ont eu la réponse
vers le mois d'avril mai donc ils nous
ont prévenu que c'était ok donc là après
on a fait la réunion publique la réunion
publique vous imaginez dans dans notre
dans un village où on vote on a voté
Marine Le Pen à 60 % et député pareil
donc rassemblement national donc ce
n'était c'était pas gagné donc ça a été
un petit peu houleux mais par contre je
m'étais fait accompagner surtout
accompagner pour qu'il y ait vraiment
cette sensation de il faut pas être seul
pour pour pour pour ce genre de projet
là donc bien sûr il y avait la
préfecture qui était là il y avait donc
donc bien sûr accueiller promotion et le
bailleur social mais il y avait surtout
l'éducation nationale qui était là avec
l'inspecteur d'académie le major de
gendarmerie qui était là donc pour avec
représentant de l'autorité et on a
assisté bon bien sûr il y avait des
affiches non réfugiés donc le le le
représentant du front nation du
rassemblement national donc bien sûr a
eu ses arguments comme
habituellement mais et puis ce qu'il y a
c'est surtout la crainte des personnes
qui était là qu'on a écouté qu'on a
entendu qu'on a essayé de rassurer
c'était la crainte des incivilités
c'était la crainte de
de de de je je ne sais pourquoi en fait
de perdre leur en fait plutôt une sorte
de jalousie de per de perdre leur emploi
qu'il ait des avantages pour eux que eux
n'auraient pas eu et puis également
qu'il y a le le prix du des
habitations baisseré à cause de ça ça n
permis d'être rassuré puis on a reçu
donc la première famille alors je suis
même allé accueillir la première les
deux premières familles donc à roissi
avec la directrice et c'était j'étais
avec mon épouse et la directrice et
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qui
nous a
on a été très très ému à ce moment-là
c'est-à-dire de voir ces deux ces deux
couples qui arrivaient donc un couple
avec un enfant sur les bras et l'autre à
la main et puis un sac un sac en
plastique dans lequel il y avait toute
leur vie qui était qui était làdedans
l'autre la dame enceinte donc appuy au
bras de son mari également avec un sac
plastique c'est c'est quelque chose de
très très émouvant les autres familles
sont arrivées après et c'est vrai qu'en
fait j'ai et je le fais toujours à
chaque fois qu'il y a une nouvelle
famille qui vient mais je vais les
visiter je vais les voir on reçoit les
cours de français de ils les font je
demande à ce qu'ils les fassent à la
mairie donc on a libéré une salle
associative et ils viennent prendre des
cours de fleu donc à la mairie ce qui
fait qu'en fait au début c'était
absolument extraordinaire de voir les
femmes avec leurs boubou AINS
traverserette village et puis donc
c'était c'était
extraordinaire on a on a travaillé aussi
avec les instites pour travailler donc
il y a eu la mise en place d'un
professeur de fleu et puis surtout donc
les professeurs du collège qui ont qui
ont accompagné aussi donc le le le
projet il a été mis en place donc le le
le principe ouvrir l'école aux parents
pour la réussite des enfants et ça je
crois que c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire parce que ça permet
donc même pour les parents qui n'ont pas
le droit de travailler qui n'ont pas le
droit ceux qui sont en cada n'ont pas le
droit au cours de français ils n'ont pas
le droit de bénéficier des cours de de
français euh contrairement à ce qu'on
croit seul ceux qui ont le statut de
réfugi il ont droit par contre S on ils
ont des enfants qui vont à l'école à ce
moment-là ils ont le droit d'avoir des
corps de français au niveau du collège
donc et je trouve que c'est ce principe
là ouvrir l'école aux parents pour la
réussite des enfants c'est quelque chose
que j'essaie de qu'on a mis en place et
puis qui est que Don dont les parents
profitent et c'est quelque chose je
trouve que on devrait le généraliser
même à la population parce qu'il faut
bien se dire qu'au niveau
rural la population réfugée et notre
population locale elle est exactement
confrontée aux mêmes difficultés
c'est-à-dire ce sont exactement les
mêmes difficultés de mobilité et la
mobilité c'est vraiment le premier des
enjeux qu'il faut qu'il faut résoudre
quand on est au niveau rural sinon on ne
s'en sort pas on n' pas l'accès aux
soins on n pas l'accès à l'emploi on
l'accès à l'information ainsi de suite
et tout ça ce sont des thèmes qui sont
qu'on retrouve chez les réfugiés mais
qu'on retrouve aussi la population
locale et je pense qu'en fait quand on
on reçoit cette population là il faut
que ça soit du gagnant gagnant il faut
qu'on puisse proposer quelque chose à la
population réfugiée mais également donc
à la population locale et là le fait
d'avoir des réfugiés par exemple je vous
don un exemple là qui est tout récent
puisquil de la semaine dernière il y
avait donc un transport à la demande
très peu de bus qui qui qui desserent
vous pour aller jusque jusqu'à la
préfecture et donc il y avait un bus à
la demande le samedi en début
d'après-midi départ 1h30 retour à 17h ce
transport à la demande donc j'ai vu avec
la région pour voir si on peouait pas le
péréniser et ce qui fait que maintenant
il est il est pérenne ce qui veut dire
que la population pourra en profiter et
on a dit également qu'on fera la même
chose le mercredi après-midi ce sont des
choses qu'on fait donc on fait pour les
les réfugiés mais qu'on fait également
donc pour la population le le fait
d'avoir un prof de fleu ça permet aussi
de travailler avec les institutrices et
d'avoir de de de ne plus avoir un niveau
supplémentaire dont elle doit s'occuper
et ça permet aussi donc de décharger un
petit peu du travail et puis qui a
surtout je je trouve que c'est très
important vous avez parlé des femmes
tout à l'heure et je pense qu'en fait
les femmes qui arrivent seules en France
j'ai eu beaucoup de femmes nigérien
souanaise surtout qui qui avait
énormément d'ambition et c'est ça qui
m'a qui qui m'émerveille à chaque fois
c'est cette ambition qu'ont les parents
pour pour pour leurs enfants et cette
volonté de vouloir s'en sortir et
d'inculter cette j'ai l'impression de de
me retrouver à mon époque où nos parents
avaient énormément d'ambition pour nous
je j'étais médecin avant j'étais
adictologue je m'occupais des enfants je
faisis des actions au niveau des du
collège je suis un peu effrayé du manque
d'ambition de de notre jeunesse
actuellement et ça par contre cette
ambition je la retrouve dans ces
populations là merci beaucoup Christian
pour
votre
merci effectivement alors on on pourra
continuer à échanger ensemble sur ce
sujet-là pendant le temps du dîner merci
beaucoup à Yam Surot pour votre pour
votre échange merci à tous petite
information très pratique pratique à
21h30 c'est le Conseil national pour les
membres et euh pour tous les membres des
villages vous avez un pot tout de suite
qui vous attend à au bar de l'accueil
voilà merci beaucoup bonne
soirée